White House press secretary Kaley Mackin
and he joins us now from Washington
Kaley
good morning as we just heard the
president said the doctor found she
wants to play both sides of the equation
what exactly did the president mean by
that well what the president means by
that is they disagree on this issue
they're on opposite sides of the
equation on this President Trump does
want to open schools and I would note
that dr. Fauci later in his testimony
did say that he doesn't believe school
reopening --zz need to be linked to a
vaccine development the President
believes we can safely reopen
he's cognizant of the many working
parents out there who are having to be
teacher
mom dad spouse and play all of these
different roles the American people are
in a very tough spot and President Trump
wants to reopen safely that would
include schools does the president still
have confidence in dr. Fatty's yes he
does he takes him to consultation the
advice of dr. Falchi but also that of
dr. Burks and also that of Stephen Hahn
and Admiral schwa and all of these
experts and then he makes the best
decision based on the data presented to
him there's a lot of voices and as dr.
Fauci noted he is one among many a new
CBS News poll Kaylee says that 62
percent of people trust dr. Falchi just
38 percent trust the president what do
you make the make of the distance
between those two numbers well I believe
that the American people have a lot more
trust and the President and that poll
indicates they've looked at this
president and they've seen a president
who has managed to deliver more in 95
respirators and the health care industry
uses it an entire year in fact three
times more we were told that there would
be a ventilator shortage but this
president has managed to secure a
hundred thousand ventilators in a
hundred days again three times more than
what is produced in the average year
they've seen a president at work and I
believe the American people have great
confidence in this president's
leadership health officials have been
saying that we're gonna see spikes and
if we don't handle the spikes correctly
they could become outbreaks what is the
president doing to manage the spikes so
they don't become outbreaks that's a
really important question as we reopen
the president said that we will see him
here and there so small outbreaks that
we have to be able to manage and
basically when you see an outbreak the
state governments many of them have put
into place contract tracing plans that
they've shown the federal government
that allow us to isolate an outbreak and
immediately put it out and I did speak
with dr. Burks and she said we've seen
many great success stories of being able
to put out these outbreaks she noted one
in Iowa and she did say to me
yesterday when I spoke to her around
five o'clock that she has not been
seeing a link between mobility and
increase in cases meaning that in
Florida for instance in Georgia for
instance we're not seeing as these
states become more mobile and increase
in cases and that's because a great
testament to the American people who are
who are about social distancing who are
watching their hands and not touching
their face and listening to the advice
of the experts the president says we
lead the world in testing but many
health officials say we still don't have
enough only a small percentage of people
in this country have been tested what is
being done to further ramp up testing as
we push to reopen because so many health
experts say it's essential it's an
important component for sure but here's
what I'd say to testing is first you
know we are doing far more than Europe
in fact two times more testing than most
European countries but we have enough to
do strategic testing each governor has
put in place a plan that they've
delivered to us saying this is the
testing I need to approached phased
reopening and I've sat with Admirals law
and task force meetings and seen him
pull out a sheet and say you know X
state you've requested this I'm ensuring
that you have this to enter phase 1
reopening so we do have enough for
strategic testing to enter phase 1 we
saw that Wisconsin has reopened on
orders of the Supreme Court there and
then we saw crowded bars in the evening
are you concerned about that happening
as as cities reopen look it's incumbent
upon every American to engage in social
distancing to wear a mask if that if you
feel that you need to at that moment
it's a recommendation by the CDC not a
dictator not a mandate but a
recommendation but nevertheless you
should wash your hands you
take into account these practices I mean
in Wisconsin the the citizens of that
state need to do the same because we
want to safely reopen and we can't
emphasize that enough
Kaleigh mackaninee thank you very much
for being with us this morning